Studio Ghibli movies have a really
special place in my heart they give me
this feeling that's actually kind of
hard to explain
oh pain Nostalgia memories of a time
when things were simple and it's not
just me these movies have captured the
hearts of so many people all over the
world because
[Applause]
it um it manages to Kindle these
Universal emotions that are at the core
of Being Human
um and the secret is in how they
carefully craft these imaginary world
what the hell is that no more AI we want
to be hand drawn you need to take care
of this stop all of this nonsense please
I'll try my best to address your
concerns okay
[Music]
um yeah so uh let's try to unpack Studio
Ghibli movies from an architectural
point of view and
um try to understand how are they able
to bring out these emotions yeah uh what
is it about the worlds that they're
building yeah and um okay let's let's
also discuss is it possible for them to
be made with AI no way this video is
sponsored and storyboarded with
millinote more on them later in this
video Studio Ghibli films come alive
thanks to the rich storylines and the
strong characters but the environment
play an equally important role in making
the films what they are
this is one of my favorite scenes from
the movie Spirited Away the main
character Chihiro who's just 10 years
old has just got there some really crazy
stuff her parents got turned into pigs
and she's really had to find her way to
survive in this very strange World by
herself and now she has to go find the
switch to ask if she could save his
friend Haku
and for almost two minutes nothing
really happens
it's just Chihiro sitting on the train
but it's potentially one of the most
powerful moments in the movie because it
gives us space to breathe and reflect on
what this character just went through
Studio Ghibli movies are full of scenes
like this empty moments where we can
process what's going on and build
empathy and a connection to the
characters and the story on a deeper
level
there's a concept in Japanese Ma
it's the space between objects or
elements
it's the time between the beginning and
the end it's the Gap the space or pause
it's the negative space but Ma is not
simply an absence of things but an act
of presence that shapes the way we
perceive and interact with the world
around us it emphasizes the tension and
interplay between objects rather than
just focusing on the objects themselves
every Studio ghibling Movie will craft
these negative spaces and negative
moments with an incredible amount of
detail specifically sensory detail
even though movies are mainly a visual
and auditory medium in moments like this
you can almost feel the dampness on your
skin or the wind in your hair
When We Touch something that's sensory
information goes from The receptors in
the skin to the spinal cord to the brain
stem then to the somodo sensory cortex
which interprets the touch at the same
time that information is also sent to
the amygdala which evaluates the
information and initiates an emotional
response the amygdala is actually
responsible for processing emotions and
for memory formation and also for memory
storage and so by heightening these
sensory details in these empty moments
we're not just looking at the objects on
the screen but we're feeling
we're feeling the haptic experiences and
we're becoming immersed in emotions and
even in memories
he says the experiences the sensory
experiences make up the animations and I
think he's saying the foundation of
every person
um this leads to good animation you can
see how this even informs how they craft
the spaces this is a pretty significant
moment from the movie Spirited Away that
marks the main character's transition
from the human world to the spirit world
again nothing really happens
[Music]
you're just left to feel the space
the entire world of Ghibli is crafted
with spaces that have this calm almost
ethereal atmosphere and I think they're
able to do this because of their unique
understanding of Shadows
[Music]
this dappled light that filters through
the trees there's a word for this in
Japanese
it's called comoribi and I think it has
this kind of ethereal otherworldly
quality to it these soft shifting
patterns of light and Shadow they're
used to create a dream-like atmosphere
in Studio Ghibli films but it's more
than that in the book in Praise of
Shadows junichiro tanizaki reflects on
the beauty of darkness and shadows and
Japanese Aesthetics especially in
contrast to Western Aesthetics he says
westerners make the most of lighting
fixtures which are designed to produce
light and practical quantities they go
to Great pains to direct light where
it's needed and yet they despise what
little Shadows remain Japanese ancestors
forced to live in dark rooms presently
came to discover Beauty in Shadows
ultimately to guide Shadows towards
Beauty's ends so Japanese they treasure
their Darkness instead of fearing it
Darkness they know is the richest source
of beauty
Shadows are also used more actively
throughout his movies to add another
narrative element like in this instance
the shadow foreshadows what's going to
be happening later because these stalls
become populated with Spirits here
Chihiro runs into Haku but just behind
him you can see the shadow moving really
fast meaning that time is passing really
fast and it's getting dark really fast
so by interjecting the story with
moments and spaces where you can pause
and by detailing those moments with
sensory elements Hayao Miyazaki is able
to create really unique and emotional
experiences
[Music]
to make this video we analyze a lot of
footage and articles and we use Milano
to organize everything melanote is
extremely intuitive and comes with tons
of templates that you can choose from
and in this case we created a scene by
scene storyboard that guided all of our
filming and post-production processes
you can very easily drag and drop images
and my favorite part is how it converts
links into thumbnails so you don't need
to download anything all of this is on
the clouds you can share with other
people very easily the best part is that
all of this is completely free and you
can sign up using the link in the
description
but all of this extra level of detail
and all of these long pauses if you're
looking at the movie from an efficiency
perspective you're actually taking away
valuable time that you could be learning
about the characters through action and
dialogue so instead what he does is he
uses the environments as a tool to paint
a fuller picture of the narrative and
the characters a really good example is
the contrast between you baba and
xeniva's homes the two sisters are twins
so by looking at their appearance you
actually can't tell who is who and you
only get a limited amount of screen time
with each character but you can get a
much more Fuller understanding of each
of the sisters by looking at their
Apartments yubaba is the head honcho of
the bath house she's the evil sister who
turned to Hero's parents into pigs she
lives right here on the top floor of the
bath house and Chihiro has to go through
a very long elevator ride to get to the
top floor before or even getting into
the apartment you have this Grand entry
experience
full of ornaments and details this
procession of rooms is called an envelon
this was a common arrangement in Baroque
palaces in the 17th century the first
room is the public room and the Royal
bedroom will be at the very end and
everything in between were estate rooms
used for entertaining you are allowed to
go as far as your rank would allow so
before we even meet you baba you get
this anticipation and the sense that
she's really at the top of the top of
the food chain then once you get to her
room it's a completely different style
from the breast of the building or the
sleeping quarters of workers which is
more understated in the traditional
Japanese style so from this you can see
that not only is she greedy for wealth
and power but she's kind of force fit
into the rest of the environment almost
in a gimmicky way
[Music]
in contrast Geneva's house is in a
remote little cottage Farm behind a
Thicket they're let through this dark
path by this magical Lamppost and the
house is simple and understated and it
looks like gets modeled after a
traditional Irish cottage from the 1850s
the interior is rustic it's warm and
cozy and fairly minimal which reflects
xaniba's humble and down-to-earth
character what's interesting is that
neither of these architectural styles
are used intentionally to create literal
connection to the Baroque Period or a
traditional Irish Cottage that's why a
lot of the times architecture is used
just as a reference but it's always a
combination of different styles to
create a certain mood or a feeling the
thing about architecture is that there's
the Learned intellectual understanding
of a building or its type but there's
also the subconscious purely emotional
connection to that space and so the
question is can these spaces or these
haptic experiences or these moments of
emptiness
can they be generated by AI
foreign
[Music]
I strongly feel that this is an insult
to life itself
bam and I understand where he's coming
from for him careful observation and
experience of the world is the key to
bringing his animations to life he makes
a direct correlation between the
personal experience and the skills of an
animator and he actually goes as far as
to say that someone who eats instant
noodles three times a day cannot be an
animator the core of what makes his
movie special the feeling the tactility
the emotions the memories all those
intangible qualities they can't be
generated by AI because they need to be
experienced first
now I do want to play The Devil's
Advocate here what are the financial
implications of this let's say for the
cost of doing one movie and getting
people to hand animate every scene every
blade of grass they could do three
movies with the help of AI
and even before AI they've been known to
produce films at a much slower speed
compared to other Studios
so can the revenue from the projects
recoup the costs
I don't know
AI is getting better and better every
single day and it is making a lot of
processes a lot more efficient but what
we do know is that pretty much every
single movie they've released since
their first International debut nausica
has been a box office hit
market tonight
personal
um
no matter how good and how convenient
technology gets we still crave The Human
Experience
I mean we've seen this through the
pandemic we still crave meeting up with
people we want to go outside we want to
travel even if it means getting in
trouble and maybe that's the one thing
about us that we can't change we are
sensory experiential creatures we need
to feel things and so if I were to
distill their strategy for Success their
secret to evoking these strange emotions
in us I think it's because they focus on
hitting that nerve that make us feel
just a little bit more alive
just a little bit more human
[Music]
thank you for watching guys what are the
kind of feelings that you get from
watching a Studio Ghibli movie and do
you think hayabus Aki needs to get with
the program and start using AI don't you
think they get it at this point
I mean it was a bit long video do you
think people watching till the end I
guess she did a really good job if
you're still here watch it
can you please stop continuing saying no
more I I think I need to go lie down
[Music]
hey where are you going don't leave
Please Subscribe please can you
subscribe
[Music]